these soldiers are on a mission
to push out islamic state fighters from
syria's northern city of hasaka
for days the area has turned into a
battleground between kurdish-led syrian
forces and isil with more attacks and a
rising death toll
here death is easy to come by lifeless
bodies of suspected isil fighters are
laid out by kurdish forces near a dirt
road
but dozens of people have been killed on
both sides
the latest battle broke out after isil
stormed the hawaiian prison which housed
more than 3 500 suspected members of the
armed group
many managed to escape and are believed
to be on the loose
now there are concerns the attacks could
signal the group's comeback three years
after it was defeated
some local leaders say support for isil
is increasing as resentment grows
against the kurdish-led administration
often accused of discriminating against
the majority arab population
we're hoping god will make things better
so we can go back home we're renting a
house but now we have nowhere to go we
have no one but god
families are leaving their homes amid a
harsh winter entire neighborhoods left
virtually empty as kurdish forces close
in on their targets
well homeless now we didn't sleep last
night we're dead walking we're dying of
fear we've been walking since this
morning and now the cold is not helping
at all
[Music]
what began as an attack on a syrian
prison may signal the start of a new
front between kurdish forces and isil
paul trader jion al jazeera